Fran what about you you chose Don Powell
mm-hmm I chose Don town I chose on
palette because I had to choose someone
although my first choice to be involved
in this project would have been to take
out 50 people as opposed to add 50
people this it always be my choice I
chose I chose Don Powell just in the
hopes that more people would read Don
Powell that every little mention of Don
Powell would help her gain a readership
because there had recently been you know
somewhat of a vogue for Don Powell
I mean relative to previous condition
where no one including myself had ever
heard of her I heard of her for the
first time probably the way most people
who have heard of her I heard of her
which is an essay that gore Vidal wrote
in the New York Review of Books I have
no ability to remember dates sometime in
the late 80s I believe you might even
know it might even be in this book and
he wrote a very long essay very
appreciative essay about Don Powell
which cause in fact a very small press
to republish certain of her novels from
New York novels in fact this was such a
small press that when they after they
had published maybe the first one and I
talked to quite a number of people about
it how great I thought it was I got a
message on my answering machine saying I
don't remember the guys name my name is
so-and-so
I own this little publishing company
published on pound we heard you like
term we'd like to know if you'd give a
blurb you may remember me I met you once
before
I am the butcher at the Jefferson Market
so he was the betrothal Jefferson market
during the day and by night he was this
very fine publisher of course
unfortunately I believe he's probably
now still the butcher at the Jefferson
market and this publishing company
doesn't exist any longer this in fact is
a history of American letters anyway Don
Powell was not unknown in her time which
I think a lot of people believe to be
the case but she was very commercially
unsuccessful in an era where there were
writers were very commercially
successful far inferior of course to Don
Powell
she was very critically well-received
particularly by Edmund Wilson who at
that time was able to really make
people's entire careers but unable in
the case of Don Powell to do this she
wrote in my opinion she has almost two
totally discrete bodies of work she has
these Midwestern novels she grew up in a
Highland very unhappy circumstances
which really probably defined anyone's
child in Ohio but she was abandoned and
you know her parents died and then the
next people she live at they died and
then they throw out them they died and
it was unusually unhappy child in Ohio
she wrote a whole series of Midwestern
ah was very good a very bleak and then
she wrote as she came to New York and
wrote these wonderfully hilarious New
York novels I think the reason that they
were not successful is their their very
harsh and there just was never a time in
this country where that was appreciated
they are exactly the opposite of stories
of redemption there is not a moment of
redemption in a Don Powell novel because
they're so real to life so their hair is
not just not even a fleeting thought of
redemption in a non pala novel and also
she did something incredibly bold and
foolish how often these things go hand
in hand
she wrote a novel about Clare Boothe
Luce
um and you know the exact moment where
that would have been just about the
stupidest thing you could possibly do if
you had any interest in earning two
cents it is really Oh funny funny book
and now see what happens is Clare Boothe
Luce is dead and we still have this
wonderful book so that but at that time
of course Clare Boothe Luce was married
to mr. Luce and so that this hurt on
Powell's career quite a bit she are she
also role plays almost everything she
wrote no one bought the these books you
know because they're their satires might
seem in a certain respect as if they
would date and because they're very
specific in in certain respects however
they really don't at all and this is
because human nature has not improved
one bit so the head although you know
bars have different names and
advertising you know is not at the
center of the of that kind of bar life
as it was at the time and when it was a
quite a new thing
and although Clare Boothe Luce is dead
many other women have come to take her
place so the head you will say that
really these exact same people are still
with us
and so if you did write such a novel now
you would have exactly the degree of
success that dawn Powell had
in her career even though you know in
most respects she is a profoundly
American writer having this incredibly
strong unshakable bond to the Middle
West and this very kind of typical
American you know a kind of story of
bohemian aspiration of coming to New
York and she's very unamerican in how
really harsh her work is and which is
why she's really one of my favorite
writers and that is why I chose nine pal
brain I'd also had a question for you
where I found in your introduction to
Don Powell get a really intriguing
statement about how her work was somehow
intact because it was neither it was
ruined neither by great success or great
failure of the of the of the author
somehow that you know that she was not
hugely lauded or demonized somehow you
know there's something in that stayed
pure you tell me a little bit more about
about sort of the idea does the success
somehow distort you know especially
something that's a written work sort of
how we view you know people's sort of
cannon from the past
well it doesn't distort a work that's
finished right it distorts the life work
for right of course it does I mean there
are numerous examples of that a success
or failure it depends on the person you
know some writers can handle success um
in fact many writers especially a writer
like Don Powell
you know I mean all satirist are very
social people they're not you know a
satirist is never a person you know who
lives in a barn in New Hampshire so
because um you have to have something to
satirize and it turns out people are
perfect for this
particularly that sort of writer often
usually that sort of writer either it
becomes very fashionable which is
tremendously problematic for a writer or
is ignored which is tremendously
enraging and that has either one can
have a very deleterious effect on
writers work you know basically don't
impose New York novels or novels and
manners and it's very unusual for a
writer like Don Val to have had neither
extreme reaction to her work because
there was you know this is very kind of
a legal but people who appreciate it
that was sufficient kind of success for
her not to take poison in the boarding
house um but she didn't really succeed
you know the way that other writers that
ilk do sometimes and so that can be
quite oppressive to a writer she had
tremendous crushing financial
obligations which is that she had a son
who was [ __ ] or brain damaged and
was institutionalized and and she had a
husband who was kind of a poet so also
very expensive type of husband half so
that but she was very and this is very
unusual for someone with that kind of a
terma turn of mind that she had she she
was kind of feisty although you know
thank goodness it does not appear in her
work there's no feistiness at all in the
work which would be death to a satirist
but she she she was very prolific I
don't think that she would have been
that prolific you know had she been very
successful because there have been too
many occasions to observe as opposed to
record to record yeah that's interesting
friendly woods made a joke about rather
than adding 50 people to the list but 50
people should get taken off so my
question is if you're if you're taking
part in these intellectual projects to
reclaim all this
territory how do you juggle that with
the idea that maybe in the popular head
there's only so much room only I mean
seriously how many people in the popular
mind can we remember and truly value
some security about how you guys juggle
those two notions you mean how many how
many people do I think the popular mind
can juggle luckily they didn't ask us
about the popular mind I don't really
understand how do you take the
conflicting issues of we have all you
know hairdresser in Cincinnati all these
narratives just to house in piles you
don't have to remember them that's why
we have books yeah right I mean that to
me that's a great thing about books is
once it's 8 you have the book you don't
have to remember it right you can look
it up again right and if you're in my
field your job is to bring more and more
back I mean when Casper and I started
talking about this you know if we could
get what 3,000 we thought that would be
a lot right but now we're up to 7,000
you know whatever and the more the
merrier if we can get 10 I mean I'd love
to have 18,000 you know black people
brought back from the dead just so that
nobody ever has to do that man you know
the the curse the mixed blessing of the
being a scholar of african-american
tradition and many other I think women's
tradition and women's studies as well is
that you're doomed of resurrect before
you explicate you have to go out and
find it you know my PhD is an English
literature if I'm writing about Milton
you know 20,000 secondary sources on
Milton and I can find them online I
could find concordances I can find all
this text I can scan them you know all
that's we're just doing that my
generation is just doing that for
African American in the african-american
tradition so my job is not to worry
about the popular mind but to say with
the more the merrier
but it also has an impact on the popular
mind you don't have to remember or know
about the individuals but once you get a
sense that there are in fact a flood of
people out there in this category that
previously was represented only by
few individuals it changes the way you
think about both the past and about the
way the world works in the present it's
not a matter of individual data it's a
matter of the impact of the collective
resurrection
I think but do you really mean the more
the merrier I mean should there should
be an ambition I presume presumably
going to be you know I mean you must
impose some sort oh sure I can't have it
because I can't have the well in that
biographical dictionary of the AME
Church in New Jersey yeah it's every
stewardess in the church but then don't
get to be and you're not gonna beat him
know that I got beaten I mean we have
but it's always arbitrary isn't it I
think they're called church attendance
now so bad scene I went to Tony we were
together in Stockholm for Toni
Morrison's a nobel-prize thing and I
never let laughs thought I'd done more
questions yes I I like to follow up on
his question and all sort of reference
the history young people do not know
history because it's not taught they
know last week maybe last month maybe
even a decade if it's hip-hop
or something like that's something pop
okay - we have the electronic error
people do not read books they go up on
the web and then print out trees okay oh
they read it online given the
distribution of knowledge or information
see a convergence - how do you convert
it to knowledge and taking your 18,000
why can I not have 20,000 a hundred
thousand and your job would be to help
me index it my Curie I want to learn
about a certain type of person where are
they
we're honest technology impact on your
job as is called scholars and keepers of
the faith of history
if one young people are not taught about
history then I'm inclined to believe in
it and so we have the electronic
distribution of masses of information
where's editing I don't agree
who you callin a scholar you must have
me mixed up with these guys I'm not a
scholar everything young people know is
history everything else they're just
guessing that's what young means so that
would be my answer the rest you have to
ask the scholars well for my in my case
I wasn't sure I understood your question
but we but I'll never say I never
stopped me before
just because I mean the the important
word in your sentences to me was reading
as long as I'm reading I don't care what
form they read and we have all kind of
tools to direct them to organize their
reading whether it's the great thing
about the internet or cd-rom is that you
can index instantly yeah you know you
can you can line up you push the button
and line up all the articles on
scientists in all these pages that's
fantastic that's great that makes things
accessible in a way that it wouldn't be
or it's much more difficult through the
24 volumes we do lesson plans for
Africana I mean I created anthing I
created a company Oh calm just to put up
free lesson plans that so a teacher
could teaching a fifth-grade science
course could figure out how to include
information about the black world even
in a 5th grade science course instantly
because teachers teach what they were
taught and they're overworked and
underpaid so you have to make it easy
for them to digest if you want to easy
for them to implement if you want to
introduce new new subject matter so I
think that we're benefited enormously by
the technological advances rather than
hampered well I'd speak up I'm but I but
I think is implicit in your in your
question the problem of information
overload and the necessity for editing
it's just that I think that there are
two different things I mean I agree that
what you want as it were is an enormous
database and the bigger the better
and then
you have to think of the kind of tools
that are useful for going into it but
most people don't absorb information
that way they absorbs through stories
and that's the job of writers and
historians and and anybody's scholars
are no you know face it and history
defined in a mad empirical way is an
infinite number of events that have
happened in the past and to recount all
of those would be infinitely boring and
take an infinite amount of time you like
reading the phone book or reading you
know just endlessly through one after
another what is important is to have
some people who go into these sources of
information and pick and choose some of
them that they think are important
arrange them in some sort of order and
flow and tell a story but for an
historian
unlike writers you can't make the stuff
up so in the more data that's been
assembled the richer the possibilities
are of the kind of story that you can
tell I think we do our bit don't we
writers and bookstores and publishers
are still continuing to do it I mean
this book it's here it's there I mean
you may cast the school system there are
parents there are bookstores there are
it's all there
we're doing our bit we hand the blame to
somebody else look I want to thank
everyone for coming out this evening and
especially to thank our panelists
here